KRISPY: OK.
We are live.
welcome to Google
TV's Developer
Office Hours Hangout.
I'm Krispy, this is Susanna.
Introduce yourself.
SUSANNA CHEN: Hi, I'm
Susanna Chen.
I'm doing testing for the Google
TV apps, and so far
I've been here for a short
time, and having fun.
KRISPY: So Susanna's going to be
helping us out, doing a lot
of testing of applications and
we're excited to have her
aboard, so welcome.
A few things in the
news today.
Well actually not today, but
over the last week or so.
October eighth saw the launch
of the new and improved Play
Store for Google TV.
This has out as an OTA update,
so if you don't have it on
your Google TV yet expect
to see it soon.
What this is going to do is
bring all sorts of wonderful
features from Play that haven't
been available on
Google TV into your Google
TV environment.
This means Google Play,
and movies.
And essentially what this means
for developers is it's
going to update a lot of other
features involving Google
Play, such as-- if
I can read this--
auto updates, subscription
billing,
and Smart app updates.
I've mentioned a few of these
things previously, so they're
rolling out with this
Google Play update.
Also the "Washington Post"
has revealed it's Post TV
app on Google TV.
This app gets you access to
the latest news from the
"Washington Post" in their
show called "The Fold".
To be able to tune in and
get lots of fresh
and interesting news.
Brazil--
we had the Brazilian launch
happen recently, and we're
very excited to have them on
board with Google TV devices.
We're seeing a lot of apps
getting constructed, and so if
you're in Brazil, welcome.
Korea--
some of you you might
have heard some
mumblings about Korea.
We've partnered with--
LG U+ has become the first
IPTV provider to offer
integrated Google TV box
for its subscribers.
Korea becomes the 10th
country in which
Google TV is available.
So this is also very exciting.
Some of you may have seen the
notices that went out with
Gangnam Style.
Check it out if you
haven't seen it.
We have a great blog post.
As always you can go to
GoogleTV.blogspot.com.
That's where we post a
lot of information.
Usually update it a couple times
a week, if not more.
It's a great source to tie-in
with whatever other
information sources you're
gathering to find out more
about Google TV.
What else is going on?
We have the GBGDC hosted Google
TV on Monday, and Paul
Carff and Les Vogel are
there right now.
DC Droids was hosting Google TV
yesterday at an event that
they put on.
I saw some really
cool pictures.
Hopefully we'll get a blog
post out there shortly.
Today there's actually Google TV
test lab going on in DC at
the Google offices.
So perhaps you're one of the
lucky few who got to go, and
test out your apps on
some of the new big
screens that are there.
I think Paul brought on of the
LG devices, one of the big
47-inches to test apps on.
We've introduced Susan,
which was on my list.
Things that are coming up that
might be of interest to you--
the LA hack-a-thon is taking
place October 26
through the 28 in LA.
So if you're in that area and
possibly interested in
participating, send an email--
crispy@google.com.
Also we have the Boulder meet
up, which is happening soon.
Boulder Droids meet
up is happening
11/13, so November 13.
And there is a test lab going
on in Boulder similar to the
one that's going on
in DC right now.
That is happening
on November 15.
So with that, I'm going
to try to tie-in my
presentation here.
So bear with me one second while
I boot up the Hangout.
Sorry for the dead air here,
none of this stuff ever works
quite out of the box.
While I'm doing this though,
I'm willing to take a live
question, so if anybody
has one, now is a
great time to ask.
Everyone goes quiet.
Nobody's got a live question?
Susan do you have a
question for me?
AUDIENCE: Actually I do
have one question.
KRISPY: All right, fire away.
AUDIENCE: What would be a way to
provide you guys an app to
test if that app requires a
server in the background?
Meaning I'm building an app
for LiffTV right now, and
[INAUDIBLE]
server on one and how would we
go about me providing the app
to you guys and get feedback?
KRISPY: That's a
great question.
The thing that would occur
to me to do would be--
if there's a way you could
provide us a test server.
Either you would set it up,
and host it, or if you had
code that could run as sort
of a local test server.
I realize that might not be
possible with all the content.
But if there was a way that
what you're trying to test
could be bundled into something
that you could send
us as well, that would
be a way to go.
Any insight into how he
might solve that?
You'd probably be doing
the testing.
SUSANNA CHEN: Yes,
I probably will.
There's a way that they submit
their application to Google,
and I think that there
is a channel that
goes through Christian?
KRISPY: Yeah probably.
Here's what I suggest you do.
Send me an email, let's
follow up offline.
We'll figure this out, and
then maybe we'll tell
everybody next time we have a
Hangout how we solve this
particular problem.
Because it is interesting,
and I recognize the
difficulty in it.
And I would like to get a
solution in place that can
handle this for other
people as well.
So I am about ready.
I am going to select my
desktop to share.
For those of you who might not
have read the Call-out, what
I'm going to be presenting today
is on advanced video.
This is the talk that I gave
at Silicon Valley code camp
two weeks ago now.
So let me just get a thumbs up
from those on the Hangout, can
you see the presentation
on the screen?
Awesome.
All right.
So let's talk about
advanced video.
I had put this together.
So those of you who might do
video production might
recognize a picture
such as this.
As you're doing video
production, you're out there
with your camera, or equipment,
or entire studio
set up and you've recorded
all your content.
This is often a lot of work.
You're doing filming, you're
coordinating schedules, you're
coordinating location, and now
you've finished all your post
production, you have to start
thinking about distribution.
That fun exciting exercise that
helps get that thing that
you've worked so hard on
out into the world.
So now with video distribution,
and Google, we
have two different powerful
distribution channels.
One being YouTube of course,
where you can upload your
video, and have it accessible
to the masses, and there's
YouTube clients on all
sorts of devices.
The one that I'm interested in
talking about today though is
the Google TV platform.
And it's exciting because
it's making its way
into people's homes.
Which is changing the way
people consume content.
Whether it be YouTube,
or other channels.
A few of the supported encodings
for Google TV--
because once you've produced
your video, you have to
consider how you're going to
compress it and encode it to
distribute it.
Not all devices are created
equal, and not all devices
offer the same decoding
mechanisms.
The ones that Google TV supports
are listed on our
site-- developers.google.com/TV.
I've captured the pertinent
information and
put it on the slide.
In a nutshell, we support
H.264/AVC.
So this supports the H.264
High Profile app, 4.1--
as well as the H.264 Baseline,
so BP for AVI.
It has limited B-frame support
though, so you have to be
careful in how you go about
encoding it if you're going to
use Baseline profile.
Now file types that are typical
for packaging with
H.264 include 3GPP, MPEG TS,
Matroska, AVIs, Flash,
QuickTime, and MTS files
which is AVCHD.
Not all of you are expected
to know this.
The world of codecs is
mind bogglingly huge.
But H.264 is probably one of the
most popular standards out
there with regards to codecs.
We also support MP4s.
This is also a legacy codec I
guess you could say, although
it does show up in a lot of
devices, and it's still in
active production--
or active use by production
companies right now.
Again the container
types for those--
3GPP, AVIs, MP4s, DivX, probably
the one that's most
famous for popularizing MP4.
And MPEG TS files.
We have some support
for VP6 and VP8.
Typically you'll find those
in WBEM and FLVs.
I'm not going to be covering
any of that
today WMV 9s and VC-1s--
those are for ASF, and Windows
support or popularized by
Windows support.
The container for that is
a WMV and MPEG TS file.
We also have support for
MPEG-2, it's not really
required for Buddy Boxes, but
Blu-Ray players, et cetera,
typically use that.
So we support pass through.
How do codecs work?
This is something that I don't
think it's enough coverage in
the stuff that we talk about.
So I'm going to briefly go over
how codecs do their job.
Essentially, if you take
a picture, you
have a lot of pixels.
Cameras now are multi-megapixel,
and all that
information for a single frame
needs to be stored in a file.
The moment you start getting
into videos with multiple
images all chained together--
you'd end up carrying around a
lot of redundant information
in a moving scene.
So video codecs typically take
the temporal aspect of all of
these images, and figure
out how to remove those
redundancies.
So what I have here on the slide
is what's supposed to
represent a bunch of
different frames.
So we have one base image--
call it an I-frame.
Not to be confused with
web technology.
I'm talking the label
of an I-frame.
The next frame that would be
displayed is not going to
contain all the same information
as that I-frame.
It's only going to contain the
deltas between the last frame
that was shown, and what
needs to be shown now.
So essentially as it changes.
Some of the more advanced
codecs-- again,
H.264 being an example--
they actually utilize three
different types of frames.
So you have key frames,
I-frames, P-frames, which are
limited deltas, and B-frames,
which are even more limited.
Now a P-frame is going to look
ahead and behind it for what
delta metadata it needs
to carry with it.
And a B-frame is only going to
look backwards for what delta
information to carry with it.
All of this together when you
encode all these images
results in a more compressed
form of the video.
So all these images are crunched
down and you don't
carry around all
this metadata.
And why do we care about this?
Well, we care about getting
small files for video for a
couple reasons.
Mainly though, it's for
reducing bandwidth.
If you have your codec reducing
the bit rate to below
the bandwidth, you are not
going to achieve the best
possible quality, because you've
reduced the amount of
information that's transmitted
too far, and there's more
bandwidth available.
Likewise if your bit rate when
you're encoding is higher than
the available bandwidth,
you end up with
the buffering screen.
So some of you might see video
like this if the bit rate is
too low, and the other case
that happens is the
buffering as I said.
And I hate buffering
screens, don't you?
They're kind of annoying.
It sort of degrades the whole
experience overall.
So the reason I'm talking about
all this is because a
lot of the content distribution
that goes on in
Google TV, it happens over IP.
And not everyone's bandwidth
is created equal.
And you should really take into
account how much somebody
might be paying for that
bandwidth, or what
availability they have.
Geographically people in less
populated areas have lower
bandwidth, and so you want to
utilize a codec that offers a
good balance between quality,
and the ability to transport
it to these devices in these
low bandwidth areas.
A few things more about encoding
since I've talked
about bit rates.
Back in the older days when we
were first learning about how
to encode video for
transmission, there was
something called constant
bit rate.
This is where every frame in the
video file would basically
be compressed to about the same
size, using quantization,
matrices, et cetera.
Constant bit rate is OK, but
it leads to inefficiencies,
and kind of large files,
or smaller
files with poorer quality.
There's this concept called
Variable Bit Rate Encoding
that takes into account how much
change there is within a
particular scene.
So you can see in this slide
here-- which the images at the
bottom are borrowed from
"Big Buck Bunny".
In a scene that has low motion,
your encoder will be
able to compress it more
because there's less
information that has to be
carried between frames.
As the scene changes and there
happens to be moderate motion,
for instance, then the encoder
could detect this, and use a
higher bit rate to encode
that part of the
scene in the video.
And then if it dropped down,
it could go back to a lower
bit rate, and then if it was
really high motion--
that is lots of deltas
between the frames--
it can go up to an even
higher bit rate form.
So you get all this bursting,
and dropping.
It's the way the graph is listed
there on the white
line, which goes up and down as
the encoding takes place.
So variable bit rate encoding,
its requirements depend on a
few things.
One happens to do with the
complexity of the image, and
its resolution.
So obviously, the bigger the
image you're trying to encode,
the more space it's
going to need.
And the various codecs that
exist out there treat the
compression part of it
differently, so something
you'll have to factor in.
There are differences between
the frames, so an action movie
versus a talking head movie--
you could use the same codecs,
same settings and you might
notice even if they were the
same temporal length--
say it was 10 minutes--
they might be encoded into files
that vary differently.
So one might be a gigabyte,
and the other
might be 200 megabytes.
So variable bit rate encoding
in summary--
its encoding adapts by lowering
the rates for simple
scenes, and bursts of high bit
rate when it's needed.
Typical parameters include
setting an average bit rate
over a 10 to 30 second period
where it allows for bursts
that go maybe up to 150%
of whatever the
normal bandwidth is.
An encoder that will provide
variable bit rate encoding, it
needs to have the ability to
look ahead, so it needs some
form of buffering to absorb
these bursts.
Now this is true on the encoding
side, and also on the
decoding side.
So some of you may be familiar
with when you
start a video online--
pick your favorite content
provider online.
You might notice it takes a
couple of seconds for that
first frame to start
showing and the
video to start playing.
This is actually due to the
client side buffering up
enough information so it can
start decoding the video.
Average bit rate--
which I've mentioned--
the encoder will attempt to
reach a target average bit
rate or file size, while
allowing for the bit rate to
vary between the different
parts of the media.
Essentially what this means is,
when you are encoding your
video, you have the ability to
say hey, I want to have the
average rate be half
a megabit.
Then the encoder's going
to take that and
use that as a bar.
And as it's going through the
video, it will try and achieve
that target average, but it
won't always honor it in a
strict way across
the whole video.
As I've demonstrated in the last
few slides, it will maybe
drop below when it's
appropriate, and it might go
as high as 150% above the
average bit rate if it's
necessary to encode a very
complicated scene.
So which bit rate should
you strive for?
How do you make these
decisions?
Where does this all
come into play?
Like I said a short time ago,
the availability of bandwidth
varies by geographic location,
and how much someone is
willing to pay.
So these numbers that I put the
slide here are just based
on a quick, rough, survey.
Nothing really scientific.
For about $10 a month you can
get two megabits of bandwidth
in a typical city or
urban environment.
For $99 a month you can get 20
megabits down, and for $70 a
month you can get a whole
terabyte megabits downwards.
But that's in Kansas
City only.
Sorry if you really want
that for $70 a month.
So if you're lucky enough to
live in Kansas City, and
you've got Google Fiber, you
don't have bandwidth problems.
So consider carefully how much
encoding or what kind of
encoding trade-off you want to
make with your video after
you've produced it.
Now I want to talk about
live streaming.
Live streaming is something that
seeks to remedy some of
the problems between deciding
what you should encode at, and
delivering to people with
varying bandwidth levels.
Now HLS--
HTTP live streaming--
it's a pretty elegant solution
to this problem.
Essentially you take a video
file and you pass it through
an HLS encoder.
And what the encoder is going to
do is actually encode into
at least three different
bit rates.
So you'll have a low bit rate,
you'll have a medium bit rate,
and you'll have a
high bit rate.
And in the end it'll produce
three video files.
I'm using a very simple
case here.
Those three video files
represent half a megabit, a
full megabit, or two megabits,
and maybe five megabits.
And you have different degrees
of quality in those videos.
They're all tied together
with something
called an Index File.
Now this Index File, it's
typically XML, there's
different formats out there.
I'm going to talk briefly
about M3U8.
I've got an example
on the next slide.
Essentially M3U8 indexes this
high, medium, and low encoding
of the video, and a
client player--
let's say Google TV--
which has loaded an M3U8 file
knows how to jump between the
high, medium, and low streams
based on the bandwidth
availability as the video's
being delivered.
Typically it uses things like
quality of service--
which I'll talk a little
bit about later--
to determine when it should
switch between
high, medium, or low.
But the essential story is you
can use HLS to create multiple
video streams of the same
video content, but at
different quality levels, and
let the client choose which
one to jump to based
on what's available
bandwidth-wise for the user.
Now something else I'm going
to point out here-- some of
the more advanced encoders allow
you to do time splicing
in the video too.
So instead of having to choose
one continuous low, medium, or
high video feed, typically the
encoder will also slice the
video temporally.
So you'll have maybe 10 to
30 second chunks of low.
So let's say we had a 10 minute
video, and we had set
our encoder to chunk it into
one minute intervals.
So I'm watching this, and my
bandwidth is such that I'm
getting the medium feed
to begin with.
And so I'm fed that first minute
of medium video to my
client, and it's playing.
All of a sudden my wife jumps on
to her computer, and starts
downloading something large, and
my bandwidth gets squeezed
down a little bit.
After that minute is up, the
client player on Google TV is
going to notice that the
bandwidth has sort of dropped
off, and the buffer is emptying,
so it might switch
me to the low feed for that
next minute segment.
And so I would continue to watch
the video, and see this
lower quality video, but
it's still playing.
And then my wife's done
downloading her file, and my
bandwidth skyrockets up
to five megabits.
Now the client player is going
to detect that the buffer is
constantly full, and that it
can actually pull more.
So it makes the decision then
to switch to the high stream
for that next one
minute segment.
So this is--
in a nutshell--
how HLS works.
And there are various encoders
you can use.
I believe you can pull this
off with FFmpeg--
don't quote me on that.
Apple I believe produces
some media encoders.
There's some third party
ones out there.
I'm not going to make any
official recommendation.
But you can search for this
using your favorite search
engine, and discover some of the
details of an encoder that
might work for your platform.
So as I've already stated, a
manifest file-- which is the
M3U8 file in the example
I just gave.
It's an index file containing
links to the
actual media files.
Each media file is referenced,
and has a different bit rate.
So what an example Manifest
file would look like is
something like this.
You have Manifest of XML, and
you've got the name space, and
then you would have some
media references.
So media with an href pointing
to the low bit rate file, and
then it has a bit rate attribute
that specifies what
its bit rate is, and then you
might have one for medium,
specifying its bit rate.
You might have one for high
and its bit rate.
These files could actually
get kind of complicated,
especially if you start getting
into temporally
chunking up your video.
Your encoder should take care
of all the gory details.
But the interesting thing to
note is you can actually open
this in an editor, and poke
around and take a look if you
need to debug something, or a
stream isn't working the way
you expected.
It gives you a point with which
to debug any problems
you might be having.
So I'm not going to go too deep
into the details of this,
this is about the extent that
I'm going to cover this part.
But there is a lot of
information that is available
that can explain all the gory
details of this, and how to
encode your media files.
I just wanted to make you
guys aware of this.
I'd already talked about the
track jumping, I guess I
should have moved to this slide
when I explained it, but
just track jumping again.
You can see here it's an example
between the different
time points in the video.
Where bandwidth is increasing as
we move from left to right.
And then after we hit T3 there,
my bandwidth starts to
get choked off again, So.
I start to gracefully degrade
into the low range again.
Now how easy is this to
implement if you're just doing
a web app for Google TV?
Pretty darn simple.
You can use the HTML-5 video
tag, So if you use video with
a source pointing to your M3U8
file, and you could add
attributes like controls,
and auto play.
That's all you need to do.
So if your video is deployed
on a CDN, or a web server
somewhere, if you literally put
this line of code in your
website or web page and
load it on Google TV,
it will start playing.
This is not true if you
try and put this
in just basic Chrome--
or Firefox for that matter.
It would work on Mac, under
Safari, because I think they
implemented it.
The point I'm trying to make
is this works on Google TV.
It's not guaranteed to work
on all other browsers.
There is mixed support for it,
but it does work on Google TV.
So a nice simple elegant way to
get a video in a web page.
This fits with the standard ways
of doing video delivery
on the web using Flash,
or HTML-5.
Some people have noted that
there's a problem with the
latest version of Flash
on Google TV.
We're looking at that, but there
really isn't too much we
can do because it is an Adobe
product, and they're the ones
who are responsible for
maintaining it.
So consider carefully if you're
going to use the latest
version of Flash for
distribution on Google TV.
Make sure you test and that the
version actually works.
We of course support a lot of
the HTML-5 video players.
Not in WebView, but definitely
in Chrome.
Now we get to talk about my--
I don't want to say my favorite
topic, but certainly
one that said breeds a
lot of controversy.
That would be DRM.
Which is another aspect of
advanced video in this space.
And I really like this graphic,
I like the blue, and
the digit stuff.
I'm not sure how well it's
showing up on the Hangouts,
but I think it looks cool.
So DRM in a nutshell--
So HSL in and of itself, even
if you use AES encryption,
it's not DRM.
You're simply protecting the
video transmission, not the
content itself.
DRM is defined as having
three core things.
One being license management,
the other being transport
encryption, and the third one
being secure decoding on a
trusted video path within
the client.
You might notice that sometimes
you try and play
media content on a nonstandard
device, and it won't play.
Well that's usually because
it's missing
trusted video paths.
And this is a confusion I'm
hoping to alleviate where the
term DRM is synonymous with
these three things--
License Management, Transport
Encryption, and Security
Decoding on Trusted
Video Path.
And Google TV has Trusted
Video Path SOCs.
SOCs are systems on a chip,
and they are provided by
certain vendors, and partners
that we have that all
integrate together, and play
nice in this video space.
So how does content
protection work?
Well, you have a server, and
it's serving up some form of
video file or media file, and
it's going to send along an
encryption key with that
file to the device.
And that device uses that
encryption key to decrypt the
video file for playback.
Now in Google TV's case
it's playing the role
of the device here.
So it needs to receive this
encryption key from whatever
server is offering it.
And then it uses that to decrypt
the video file, and
then it's going to pass it along
another secure channel--
that is HDMI with HDCP.
Google TV has imbued in it the
HDCP keys that allow to
communicate over issue by HDMI
to secure screens like
televisions to play back that
content on the screen.
So there's actually two forms
of encryption and
decryption going on--
on the whole video path from
wherever the content is being
served from, to the screen that
it's being served on.
So I'm going to walk
you through a
typical scenario here.
You've got Google TV and it
wants to watch some URL.
So it goes, hey, content
server, can I
please watch this URL?
And the content server
says well you could,
but you need a license.
You need to go here
and get this.
Here's the URL, go take
care of the licensing.
So Google TV's client
then goes to
that URL for the license.
So it asks the license
server hey, can I get
a license for this?
And the license servers says no,
you need to pay for that,
go here to make payment.
So then Google TV's client
posts payment data to the
payment server, and the payment
server will inform the
license server that this
particular client
has paid for it.
And if the payment server will
send a token back to the
client on the Google TV.
And then the Google TV will ask
for the license again from
the license server providing
the token that it received
from the payment server.
The license server will then
go, hey, you paid.
Here's your URL unlock
with license key
on a separate channel.
And then Google TV will go back
to the content server
with the URL, and provide
some form of license key
validation.
And the content server will
start sending encrypted data
back that the client can play.
So in a nutshell--
this is a very simplistic
view, by the
way, of how DRM works.
For illustrative
purposes only.
But through these mechanisms
this is how DRM works.
Back to Trusted Video
Paths for a minute.
So I've mentioned SOCs.
SOCs are systems on a chip.
They're isolated from the open
circuits that handle
application code.
So on a Google TV device,
there is circuitry that
handles the Android operating
system, and all the
application space stuff
that goes on.
And then there's a completely
separate and isolated set of
circuits that handle the Trusted
Video Path content.
These are the things that come
in over through Widevine and
PlayReady, and make their way
to the actual video screen.
Now this prevents access to the
raw bits that represent
the media frames from any
of the application data.
There's requests a lot of the
time for-- hey can I access
the content that's coming
in from the HDMI input?
Well, no you can't, and
this is kind of why.
Android doesn't have
access to that.
It's all on this separate
circuitry area.
That keeps the content
safe and protected
for the content owners.
The DRM key decryption is
completely isolated from
Android as well.
This again is where
SOCs come in.
They're circuits on a chip.
I would find it remarkably
difficult to try and pop a
chip open and solder
things on there.
I don't think that's a
reasonable thing to do anyway.
But all of this is to help bring
premium content from the
big content producers to your
TV through Google TV, and
build services on top.
So I just wanted to cover a
little bit about Trusted Video
Paths there.
So as I've mentioned, at Google
TV we're trying to keep
your content safe.
So we have several
DRM components.
One being that we're built on
the Android DRM framework.
Which it manages the playback
rights of content through that
illustration I gave
a few slides ago.
We support Widevine
and PlayReady.
It's built into the
platform, and will
continue to be supported.
We have Trusted Video Path--
as I've mentioned-- and it
keeps your decrypted video
data securely in
the hardware sandbox.
It protects your streamed media
securely, so if you're
transmitting your media using
Widevine or PlayReady it will
utilize the Trusted Video Path
for that media playback.
As I mentioned a few slides
ago, the HDMI content
protection protects the video
content all the way to the
television set.
So this offers end-to-end
protection of the media as it
moves from the internet or cable
provider through to your
video screen.
A little bit about the
Android DRM stack--
you can read a lot more about
this on the Android site, so
you can go to
developer.android.com.
Search for DRM, and you can read
up on a lot of the gory
details of how this
is implemented.
Now on traditional Android, the
DRM framework is offered
as a software package where
you could actually build
additional DRM solutions--
custom ones--
but those typically require
native code, and they're
difficult to develop.
Now Google TV being a slightly
different type of Android
device, we don't support NDK.
I think I saw a question for
that in the DORY, so I'll get
around to answering why
when we get to that.
So because of this, developers
are not able to provide their
own solutions.
And we go ahead and use the same
Android DRM framework but
with our code, and put
it into the Google TV
Stack so it's available.
So if you have a really
compelling DRM solution that
is in wide use by large
content producers or
providers, then you should let
me know, and I'll put a
feature request in and see if we
can get it rolled into the
stack as well.
A couple things about Widevine,
which is a Google
owned DRM solution.
You can go to widevine.com
to find out all sorts of
wonderful things about it.
A few quick facts-- it's
supported by 540 million
devices, including 284 million
television and set-top boxes.
So that's got some wide
adoption out there.
It supports adaptive streaming,
and quality of
service controls.
PlayReady--
which I mentioned also--
it was developed by Microsoft
with collaboration within the
PCTV and mobile industry.
It also supports adaptive
streaming
and quality of service.
You can go to
microsoft.com/playready to
learn more about the details
of it there.
PlayReady itself-- the DRM for
Google TV our [? base ?]
Google TV devices that is the
newer models that are on the
market will include support
for PlayReady.
The older ones I think are
lacking some of the chip sets
that are required to
pull this off.
So just be aware if you are
going to use PlayReady, that
that might be a problem.
It's implemented as a plug-in
on the DRM framework which
I've already mentioned.
It supports license acquisition
through the APIs.
And the management tools is
extensible to adapt to custom
licensed servers that we can
play back through the Trusted
Video Path hardware.
So an example--
an Android example--
a nice, simple Android
example.
What you can do is actually
write an Android application
that plays back video in about
four lines of code.
And if you're clever,
you could do it in
three lines of code.
So essentially you want
to take a URL.
Let's say we took an M3U8 URL.
Create a string.
Drop your URL in there.
Create a Video View Object.
You can use your declarative
layout to sort of place a
video view and then
just grab it.
You set videoview.setvideopath
to the URL that you placed in
your string.
And then you do videoview.start.
And guess what?
You'll have video playing
on your Google TV.
Four lines of really
simple code.
This is a good way to start
playing with just layouts that
include video.
As you move into the more
complicated stuff, there's a
lot of tutorials online
that can help you
evolve your video solution.
If you want to start getting
into media control--
Play, Pause, Rewind,
Skip Ahead--
that's what I mean by the
more advanced stuff.
We have documentation on that.
I'm not going to be covering
that today due to time
limitations.
But I wanted to make
you aware of it.
And those of you who have
not written a Google TV
application yet, this
is a really good
way to test it out.
Especially if you
have a device.
There's nothing more compelling
than plugging in a
few lines of code and seeing
something on the screen.
I know that's what excites
me anyway.
I've mentioned quality of
service a few times, and where
quality of service comes in,
and why it's important is--
Let's say you are a large
content producer and you're
offering videos for
people to rent.
Some big company maybe that
starts with an A. You want to
pay attention to the quality
of the video
that the user is watching.
If I've spent $5 to rent a
movie, and I've paid for it to
be in HD, and I'm playing it,
and my bandwidth starts to
taper off, and it drops down
to the standard definition
video, then am I getting
what I paid for?
How can an application detect
when a certain quality
threshold hasn't been met?
Do I get a partial refund?
Do I get a complete refund?
What happens if my bandwidth
completely drops off and I
don't get to enjoy
the whole video?
This is where quality
of service comes in.
So we have quality of service
APIs that allow you to monitor
the video playback while
a video is streaming.
This is typically implemented
using a listener pattern, so
you would implement a media
player on Info Listener.
You would register your listener
with the media
player, and it would notify
you of info events
periodically that you could
monitor so you could get
current frames per second.
You can get how much space
is left in the buffer.
There's a whole bunch of really
valuable statistical
data you can grab through the
QoS APIs that would allow you
to make an informed decision as
to, hey, has this customer
actually received the quality
of service that we offered
them when they paid for it?
So again--
you can implement this
very easily.
You just need to create a
listener that implements
mediaplayer.oninfolistener.
I'm not going to cover the code
specifics due to time
limitations, but you can go to
developers.google.com/TV, and
jump in and find out
more about QoS.
If you have questions
about QoS, feel free
to send me an email.
Krispy@google.com I'll
do my best answer it.
Even better though--
is if you post your question on
Stack Overflow, and label
it with Google TV.
Because then I can find it.
I can answer it.
And other people can enjoy the
benefits of that answer in the
future, as opposed to me just
receiving one email and
responding one-off,
again and again.
So I'm going to revise that.
Post your question on Stack
Overflow, and I will find it
and answer it.
I'm going to mention the YouTube
Android media APIs.
These were announced initially
at I/O. We're still waiting
for them to go public.
I'm anticipating soon.
I don't know when though.
What the YouTube Android media
API allows for is playing back
high quality video content
on Android devices--
and this includes Google TV.
You could write code that you
creates your own YouTube
channels, and adds levels of
interactivity around this.
Essentially, it's an API that
allows you to have a video
view that is tied to
content on YouTube.
So there's a link at
the bottom there,
http://goo.gl/V4dGE.
That's a link to the video
presentation that was given at
I/O, I think it's about
an hour long.
It's worth watching if you're
interested in this.
And it's expected soon.
I don't know when
unfortunately.
I've got a QR code, I don't
think it'll do you much good
in the video stream.
I'm not sure how good that's
going to come out.
But Google TV apps can now play
high quality content as
I've alluded to.
Stay tuned for this.
I will be touting it the
Wednesday after it's launched,
whenever that happens to be.
So be aware of it.
Oh, great, we're at
the last slide.
That brings me to the
end of these slides.
And we can jump into questions,
which is awesome
because I wanted to leave
enough time to
get to these questions.
While I'm transferring over
here, has anybody got any live
questions that I can answer?
Nobody?
Everybody's shy today?
All right.
I'm just going to call up the
moderator, and let's see if we
can't answer a couple
of questions here.
I'm going to the wrong
place apparently.
This is the first time I've
done this without
Les here for a while.
VIKRIN: Can you hear me?
KRISPY: I can hear you,
yes, go ahead.
VIKRIN: Hey, how's it going?
I just want to do a quick
introduction for you.
This is the Vikrin.
KRISPY: Hi Vikrin.
How're you?
VIKRIN: How're And we
have William, who's
another lead here.
KRISPY: Hello.
VIKRIN: I just happened to jump
in, and join the Hangout,
looking at the presentation.
KRISPY: Awesome.
Did it come across
clear enough?
VIKRIN: Yeah.
Do we have access to the
PowerPoint after?
KRISPY: I'm going to make these
slides available soon.
I've been pulled in many
different directions over the
last few weeks, and
I am behind on
getting my slides published.
What I will do when they are
published is I will put a post
in the Google+ Google
Developers TV page.
And also probably mention it in
the next Hangout that we're
going to do.
So also to fill you guys in,
we're moving to a two week
format for Hangouts.
We're not going to do
it every week now.
We're going to do
every two weeks.
Partially because we have
a lot of things
going on right now.
And I want to make sure that we
have enough time to prepare
Hangouts that are of a
certain quality, and
value to you guys.
So this gives you guys enough
time to ask a lot of questions
in the DORY or the moderator.
If you can mute?
Yay, muted.
Yeah, so we're going to move
to a two week format.
There's going to be some more
planning that goes on in here.
We're going to try and
spruce up the quality
level of these Hangouts.
So just be aware it won't
be every week.
It'll be every two weeks now.
If there's no other live
questions right now I'm going
to jump right into
the questions.
So we have five questions
this week.
Is there any way to tell the
LiveTV stream to be quiet?
I've tried requesting Audio
Focus, but it doesn't seem to
be working.
I'd rather not have to pop
the user out of LiveTV.
This is by Yosi.
My understanding is that the
LiveTV app should actually be
respecting Audio Focus.
If it's not--
and admittedly I haven't
tested this--
if it's not doing that,
please file a bug.
I think it's Google TV issues.
Please go there, and provide as
much detail as you can, and
I'll have someone take
a look at that
if that's not behaving.
Also if you an NPK that you
don't mind sharing with me,
send it my way, and I can
install it on one of the
devices I have that uses
the direct stream
from a cable provider.
We'll see if it's problem on
your device, or on all
devices, or what have you.
OK next question--
integration with my DVR.
AT&T U-verse works, but
can be cumbersome.
Is there any way to improve the
IR code mapping so that I
can set up a button that
triggers Record
TV on my DVR remote?
Is there an API for
the IR Repeater?
That's a really great
question.
Unfortunately, the
answer is no.
Mainly because I don't think
it's an exposed API yet.
But you think it would make
an interesting feature.
So I guess the answer
to this one is put
in a feature request.
Provide a little bit more detail
than you have here, use
case, et cetera.
And I can make sure that the
right eyeballs see that, and
we can see what we
can do about it.
Next question is when will
Google TV start supporting NDK
to make apps?
So interesting thing
about NDK.
I've answered this
a few times.
I've jumped into the
issues forum and I
posted an answer there.
I don't think this is
going to go away.
I want NDK too.
The reality is we can't have
it yet, and it's mainly
because of some of the legacy
work that went on in
supporting Chrome
in the earlier
generations of Google TVs.
Technical trade-offs had to be
made, and the unfortunate
consequence of that is that
NDK is not supported.
Now at the time this decision
was made NDK really wasn't a
huge part of the whole stack,
and we didn't quite know how
it was going to hook in.
So we recognize that NDK is
important to a lot of
developers who want to produce
games specifically, and a few
other things on Google TV.
I'm fighting for you guys.
I'm trying really hard
to get NDK going.
Everyone here has heard
me and is aware of it.
These things take a little bit
of time to make happen.
It's unfortunately not just
flipping a bit here or there.
There's some large changes
that we're hoping to make
which in the future should
allow for this.
So unfortunately, my answer
for this is stay tuned.
Just stay tuned.
I have nothing else to announce
at this time.
Next question--
is there a Google TV
API to support
stereoscopic 3D content?
Ooh, I like that.
There's a link here
to stack overflow.
It says FYI--
LG Google TV has 3D world
application that supports 3D.
Yes it does, and I've used
it, and I like it.
I dig the feature.
I do think stereoscopic 3D is
a little bit of a gimmick.
You don't want to be using
it all the time.
But there are times when it's
appropriate, and I think it
would be cool to be able to
build using some form of
stereoscopic 3D API.
Does it exist?
No.
It's unfortunate, but
it would make an
interesting feature request.
I'd say put it in.
Yes LG has it.
LG is the only one
that has it.
And LG is an OEM partner.
So they have a certain level of
access to things that the
general public doesn't.
And this covers all sorts of
business cases that I'm not
going to get into.
Suffice to say it's not
available, I think it would be
compelling.
So Jared please file a feature
request, and again I'll make
sure that the right people
see it, and we'll
see what we can do.
But I can't make any promises.
All right, I hope that works for
an answer, that's the best
I can give right now.
Last question on this list is
do you see AR for Google TV
GUI coming someday?
I'm going to make a leap because
I can infer all sorts
of meanings for AR.
I'm going to suppose it means
augmented reality.
I don't know.
I mean it would be kind of
weird to have augmented
reality within the GUI.
Parts of this would probably
require some form of access to
the Direct Video Overlay, and
that might be an issue if the
content is being delivered
through DRM.
I could see it happening in
the future at some point.
I think a lot of things
would have to change.
I think a lot of the laws
And a lot of the copyrights,
and patents, and
privacy, and whatnot.
I think it'd be cool.
If you're passionate about
stuff like that, my
recommendation is maybe create
an Ignite talk, or Ignite
presentation, and start putting
that idea out in front
of crowds of passionate people,
and see what you get
as feedback, and then try
and make it happen.
If you come up with some really
compelling cases for
it, and can demonstrate that
there's a demand and a need,
then if that message gets heard,
then maybe all the
right things could happen
in the future.
So I realize that's sort of
a wishy-washy answer.
Did I answer it?
Well, yes and no.
But that's unfortunately the
nature of this is kind of an
industry and space is that
it's rare that you get a
blunt yes or no.
Unless you're asking about a
specific feature, yes, no.
I've got no more questions that
are on the moderator.
I keep calling it DORY, that's
our internal name for it.
I don't see anything.
I see a few questions in
the chat stream here.
Invite please, invite please.
For those who are trying
to get on the Hangout--
you just have to go to
developers.google.com/live,
and there's a link I believe
from there on YouTube, or you
can go to our pages and
click on Join Event.
I got nothing else guys, so if
there's no other questions--
Jason, go ahead.
JASON: I had one question.
Is there a file size limit
on the APK for Google TV?
KRISPY: Well you've got a hard
physical limitation.
I would not go over
two gigabytes.
In fact I would question going
over 50 megabytes.
There's not a lot of storage
space on Google TVs.
I think the standard right
now is about four gigs.
I believe, one of the models
has eight gigs.
You want to keep your APKs
as small as possible.
And I think if you want to
bundle a lot of assets, or
content, make those available
after the fact, so that way
they can be loaded
and unloaded.
That's my suggestion there.
JASON: And then I had
another question.
The Google TV data sharing
library is that going to be
updated or [INAUDIBLE]?
KRISPY: I don't know,
I actually
haven't touched those.
But you what, I can ask.
I can ask one of the other
guys on the team what the
status of that is.
Maybe send me an email just to
remind me, so I don't forget.
And I'll figure that out, and
make a post or update the
documentation or something.
All right?
Did you enjoy the Hangout?
You're very quiet today.
I know I was doing a
lot of the talking.
SUSANNA CHEN: That's OK.
All the information
is wonderful.
And I'm learning as everybody
explains it the same way.
KRISPY: Cool.
Now you guys are the ones
who are at Hangout
live here with me.
Are you guys finding
this valuable?
Should I keep up this format
going forward?
JASON: I definitely
like the slides.
KRISPY: All right.
So I'll prepare something
for two weeks from now.
So two weeks from now,
we'll do another one.
I'll figure out the topic this
week, and I'll start posting
it so you guys know what
questions to start asking or
thinking about.
All right?
So with that, I will
bid you adieu.
And we'll tune in in two
weeks and reconnect.
All right guys?
Take care.
SUSANNA CHEN: Bye.